do you think Skynet is at all a
possibility oh yes
well like the actual sort of uh
autonomous uh weapon system kind of
thing do you worry about that uh stuff
I 100 worry about it and so the I mean
the uh you know some of these uh fears
of AGS and how this will plan out I mean
these will be like very powerful
entities probably at some point and so
um for a long time there are going to be
tools in the hands of humans uh you know
people talk about like alignment of agis
and how to make the problem is like even
humans are not aligned uh so
uh how this will be used and what this
is going to look like is um yes
troubling so do you think it'll happen
so slowly enough that we'll be able to
as a human civilization think through
the problems yes that's my hope is that
it happens slowly enough and in an open
enough way where a lot of people can see
and participate in it just figure out
how to deal with this transition I think
which is going to be interesting I draw
a lot of inspiration from nuclear
weapons because I sure thought it would
be it would be [ __ ] once they develop
nuclear weapons but like it's almost
like
uh when the when the systems are not so
dangerous they destroy human
civilization we deploy them and learn
the lessons and then we quickly if it's
too dangerous we'll quickly quickly we
might still deploy it uh but you very
quickly learn not to use them and so
there'll be like this balance that you
humans are very clever as a species it's
interesting we exploit the resources as
much as we can but we don't we avoid
destroying ourselves it seems like
well I don't know about that actually I
hope it continues
um
I mean I'm definitely like concerned
about nuclear weapons and so on not just
as a result of the recent conflict even
before that uh that's probably like my
number one concern for society so if
Humanity uh destroys itself
or destroys you know 90 of the people
that would be because of nukes I think
so
um and it's not even about full
destruction to me it's bad enough if we
reset society that would be like
terrible it would be really bad and I
can't believe we're like so close to it
yeah it's like so crazy to me it feels
like we might be a few tweets away from
something like that yep basically it's
extremely unnerving but and has been for
me for a long time
it seems unstable that world leaders
just having a bad mood
can like um
take one step towards a bad Direction
and it escalates yeah and because of a
collection of bad moods it can escalate
without being able to
um
stop
yeah it's just it's a huge amount of
power and then also with the
proliferation I basically I don't I
don't actually really see I don't
actually know what the good outcomes are
here uh so I'm definitely worried about
that a lot and then AGI is not currently
there but I think at some point we'll
more and more become something like it
the danger with AGI even is that I think
it's even less likely worse in a sense
that
uh there are good outcomes of AGI and
then the bad outcomes are like an
Epsilon way like a tiny one way and so I
think um capitalism and humanity and so
on will drive for the positive
uh ways of using that technology but
then if bad outcomes are just like a
tiny like flipping minus sign away uh
that's a really bad position to be in a
tiny perturbation of the system results
in the destruction of the human species
it's a weird line to walk yeah I think
in general what's really weird about
like the Dynamics of humanity and this
explosion we've talked about is just
like the insane coupling afforded by
technology yeah and uh just the
instability of the whole dynamical
system I think it's just it doesn't look
good honestly yes that explosion could
be destructive and constructive and the
probabilities are non-zero in both